bueno señalarle que la audiencia comenzó
con retraso ya se ha visto que el
abogado Roberto ha dicho que Toledo no
participa porque se encuentra ahí desde
su ingreso a la cárcel de barbadío y
está bajo tratamiento médico la defensa
de Alejandro Toledo ha comenzado a
petarrear las acusaciones de la fiscalía
sobre colusión sostiene que existen
contradicciones respecto al lugar donde
el ex mandatario supuestamente habría
recibido Los 35 millones de dólares de
funcionarios señala que los Testigos se
contradicen a lo largo del expediente
porque uno señalan que la reunión fue en
palacio de gobierno en Lima y otros
afirman que fue en Brasil respecto a la
acusación por colusión la defensa de
Toledo rechaza lo dicho por la fiscalía
porque señala que no hay una precisión
en los montos y en a lo largo del
expediente en algunas páginas 35
millones de dólares luego 28 de dólares
28 millones de dólares y después 30
millones de dólares es por eso que el
juez Richard Concepción le ha pedido a
la fiscalía que haga una precisión al
respecto y le ha dado un plazo para que
subsane los errores bueno Y cuál es la
situación de Toledo en la cárcel de
barbadillo
Alejandro Toledo se encuentra débil
según ha revelado su abogado Roberto su
afirma que el mandata ex mandatario
padece de Cáncer y tiene dolencias es
por eso que el letrado ha solicitado la
presencia de una junta médica para que
evalúe a Toledo y ordene el cuidado que
debe tener el expresidente y algo que no
le ha caído tampoco bien a Toledo ni a
su defensa es que un tribunal haya
admitido a trámite una demanda que exige
que ocho inmuebles que le pertenecen a
Toledo y su familia pasen a nombre del
estado esto se da en un caso de lavado
de activos que se le sigue a Toledo su
esposa y su suegra Mientras tanto
Alejandro Toledo Tiene 18 meses de
prisión preventiva que cumplir
curiosidades de la vida en una cárcel de
barbadío donde también va a ser vecino
de prisión de su principal rival
político el expresidente Alberto
fujimori